si dans ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'intérieur car le
limogeage justifier du préfet de police
est un événement sans précédent sous
l'histoire de la vème république le
sénat n'a pas manqué d'alerter le
gouvernement il ya eu la commission
denquête de mon collègue grosdidier la
loi anti-casseurs du président
retailleau à deux reprises le budget
pourtant régalien a été rejetée par
cette assemblée le budget du ministère
de l'intérieur
il ya eu une demande de la cour des
comptes j'ai moi même proposé un rapport
sur les commissions des finances sur le
renseignement intérieur et sur la
préfecture de police
malgré cela quatre mois après le saccage
de l'arc de triomphe et les champs
elysées sont en ruine la france veut
propager l'image de la paix en afrique
en syrie mais elle est incapable de
l'assuré au parisien à quelques
encablures de l'elysée alors ma question
est simple monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur
dans quels délais vous vous engager
vis-à-vis de vos hommes vis à vis des
parisiens vis-à-vis des français à
rétablir l'ordre
on raconte la parole et au secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur laurent du lez
monsieur le monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur philippe dominati
vous évoquez donc les d'abord le
limogeage du préfet de police ensuite
les incidents graves très graves qu'il y
a eu samedi dernier effectivement sur
les champs-elysées vous évoquez quatre
mois de tension extrême je vais vous
rappeler que et vous avez raison de
rappeler les incidents très graves qu'il
y a eu le 1er décembre sur les
champs-elysées qui nous avaient conduits
avec christophe castaner immédiatement
et de manière totalement inédite à
revoir totalement la doctrine de gestion
de l'ordre public en donnant comme nous
le demandaient les policiers comme nous
le demandaient les policiers les
organisations syndicales de policiers
beaucoup de mobilité de réactivité de
capacité d'interpellation et de
déconcentration des pouvoirs de décision
et samedi après samedi pardon mais vous
ne pouvez pas parler de cas au samedi
après samedi il y a eu le 8 décembre il
y a eu dès samedi où nous avons évité
tant d'exactions temps de pillage et
peut-être même monsieur le sénateur
philippe dominati peut-être même des
morts vous savez que c'est un curseur
important en matière de gestion de leur
public et c'était partout vrai à paris
comme en province
alors oui samedi samedi dernier il y a
eu un vrai dysfonctionnement car cette
doctrine réactive d'interpellations elle
n'a pas été mise en ordre en oeuvre
pardon alors même que nous avions donné
des instructions extrêmement précises
avec christophe castaner en ce sens et
c'est ce qui nous a conduit à renforcer
encore plus sa doctrine et comme vous le
savez le premier ministre a annoncé
désormais tout attroupement qui risquent
de présenter un caractère volent violent
sera immédiatement dispersés et seront
prises à l'appui de ces mesures
des arrêtés d'interdiction qui seront
conclus avec chacun des maires concernés
et qui permettront de venir appuyer ces
mesures de dispersion d'attroupement
mais permettez moi d'insister vous le
savez très bien monsieur le sénateur
philippe de lunettes il vous savez très
bien qu'à paris des débordements matière
d'ordre public il y en a eu plein
d'autres et sous d'autres quinquennat
sous d'autres quinquennat et il faut
toujours savoir apprécier ces questions
d'ordre public et c'est l'ancien haut
fonctionnaire spécialiste des questions
de sécurité qui vous le dis avec
beaucoup de modestie et d'humilité
entre 2007 et 2012 il ya aussi beaucoup
d'incidents en matière d'ordre public
monsieur dominati tout d'abord je
voudrais faire une observation
en préambule le fait monsieur neige que
vous me répondiez vous attire la
sympathie de gt me cycle car nous avons
tous compris que vous étés deux
prochains fusible ma question s'adresser
au ministre de l'intérieur le ministre
de l'intérieur qui a peu de temps était
le chef d'un parti politique qui dans 18
circonscriptions à paris et représentée
par quatorze parlementaires et on dirait
pourtant que le gouvernement est sourd
il entend pas l'exaspération des
parisiens il entend pas le désespoir de
ceux qui ne peuvent plus travailler
ils n'entendent pas partout même à la
périphérie
le fait que le tourisme l'activité
économique la justice la délinquance
l'antisémitisme explose parce que vous
n'arrivez pas à résoudre un problème et
à paris le parisien souffre déjà des
difficultés provoquées par l'homme et
lyon est en réalité nous sommes nous ici
victime de la double peine l'unc
considération du gouvernement
l'incompétence de la mairie et c'est en
cela que je voulais exprimer quelque
chose au ministre de l'intérieur
si les copies
[Applaudissements]